l'homme d'affaires pierre lassonde va
quitter en mai prochain la présidence du
conseil de l'entreprise qu'il a cofondée
franco nevada
il deviendra président émérite après
avoir dirigé pendant trente cinq ans une
entreprise de redevances aurifère
extrêmement prospère que deviendra donc
pierre lassonde et quelles sont ses
prévisions pour le marché de l'or voici
une entrevue réalisée il ya quelques
jours avec pierre lassonde monsieur la
sonde bonsoir bonsoir de pierre lassonde
vous avez créé franco nevada
si je me trompe pas au début des années
80 avec ses murs couric
oui on est venu public septembre 1985
voilà et donc c'était vraiment la
première entreprise de redevances
aurifères en bourse aujourd'hui vous
quitter prochainement le poste de
président exécutif
dites nous pourquoi ben écoute et à près
de 34 ans à l'abord de cette compagnie
là je pense que ces temps de céder la
place à des plus jeunes et surtout j'ai
mis en place une succession formidable
tant au conseil d'administration que
dans la compagnie allemande alors je
suis je pense que c'est le temps de
partir quoi c'est le temps de partir il
ya un moment où il faut partir
oui un moment où vous savez c'est le
temps de renouveler le conseil ce que
j'ai fait dans les cas cinq dernières
années planifie tout ce le
renouvellement du conseil de telle sorte
que l'âge moyen plus 55 ans que 65 ans
ou plus et peut ensuite renouvelé aussi
au niveau de la compagnie elle-même
comme le président et puis les
vice-présidents et ou alors on a une
jeune équipe qui est prête à prendre la
relève et surtout quand je regarde à
monsieur harcouët à arc qui va me
succéder alors david c'est lui qui a
vraiment pris ce que j'appelle franco de
numéro 2 de 2008
lorsqu'on a racheté la compagnie jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et je dois dire que les
lèvres maintenant dépassé le maître
alors ces temps de l'ue qui prennent la
place mais en même temps on vous
considère
dans le monde dès lors comme un maître
justement les gens vous demande ce que
vous en pensez demande votre avis
veulent savoir quels sont les
projections les prévisions que vous
faites et c'est votre passion
alors vous avez encore toute la
crédibilité et tout le professionnalisme
pour poursuivre quand même ah oui
écoutez je ne quitte pas le domaine du
tout du tout en fait j'ai partir une
petite boutique banque marchande qu'on
appelle oui avec trois autres bonhomme
et puis on fait de nouveau de nouvelles
transactions j'ai déjà partie de deux
autres compagnies alors écoutez jolies
dents ça c'est pas que je vais me mets
qui tirait ensuite on m'a promu si vous
voulez comme comme président honoraire
savent ça vient en fait d'un mot latin
qui veut dire c'est en partie mal et pas
trop loin on veut quand même vous posez
une coupe de questions pour savoir
comment ça va mais justement comment ça
va j'écoutais je vous écoute est
récemment conférence à denver des
entrevues vous avez donné vous dites que
les deux à sept prochaines années seront
incroyable dans leur dites nous pourquoi
ben écoutez c'est bien simple lorsque
vous regardez à l'europe en particulier
il ya 17 milliards de dollars américains
de bon et émis par les gouvernements
français allemand et tous qui se
transige à des valeurs négatives c'est à
dire que vous payez le gouvernement pour
garder votre argent parce que le
le taux de rendement et 0.5 - 0.56 alors
que vous payez alors ce qui arrive ici
qu'il ya énormément de gens qui se
disent bien coûter tant qu'à être sûr de
perdre de l'argent
je préfère acheter des lingots d'or ou
au moins je vais avoir la chance de
faire de l'argent et ce qu'on voit en
europe et puis dans les grandes familles
avec qui tison si vous voulez des camps
de fortune
on voit de plus en plus d'achats d'or et
c'est ce qui fait par exemple que le
nord tf il est un sommet maintenant qui
est seulement été une fois auparavant
alors c'est ça qui bouge le prix de la
wii
et si parce que moi je pense que le
l'administration américaine le vue
d'évaluer la devise américaine alors
soit monsieur tron ça fait déjà trois
ans qui en parle il n'y a pas été
capable de le faire mais un jour il va
réussir à faire et le ce jour là c'est
quand les banques de 30 ans du
gouvernement américain vont se
transigent une valeur négative à ce
moment là vous allez voir 5000 $ l'once
et on sera en récession vous pensez pas
nécessairement pas nécessairement encore
c'est ça qui est des kids are parce que
le haut mais tellement tu les banques
centrales mais tellement d'argent dans
l'économie que par exemple on aurait
prédit une récession il ya trois ans il
ya deux ans cette année et les polos
encore moins alors c'est pas sûr sûr
qu'il va y en avoir une récession c'est
bien sûr mais qu'est ce que ça va être
l'an prochain dans deux à trois ans y a
personne qui peut dire et en même temps
les banques centrales sont des acheteurs
nets d'or
pourquoi oui bah écoute et en fait ça
encore là c'est causé par monsieur trump
parce qu'avec toutes les avec l'iran
avec la russie avec toutes les blocages
qu'il fait de l'économie un peu partout
ces pays-là se disent bien coûter
pourquoi nous on voudrait aider les
états unis en achetant de l'or de ville
ce alors il se diversifie et ce qu'ils
font ils achètent de l'or ce qui était
en fait la grande
ce carton on parle des années 20 30 40
les banques centrales des tenait en
grande partie de l'or dans leurs
réserves et dans les années 80 90 et au
début des années 2000 ils ont tout vendu
sauf l'allemagne l'italie
mais l'angleterre le canada ils ont tout
vendu et la france on a vendu et
aujourd'hui les banques centrales de
ould dehah a vu la russie la chine le
surtout la chine énormément le pakistan
avait un paquet de banques centrales qui
ne veulent plus vraiment se concentrer
dans dollars américains achètent de
l'horesca avant ils vendaient 400 tonnes
aujourd'hui j'achète 600 tonnes
m'écouter c'est milton de différence
dans un marché de 4000 tonnes cet énorme
sur le nez un pack énorme énorme et donc
là vous avez dit 5000 je vous ai entendu
dire peut-être plus que ça 12 mai
peut-être jusqu'à 25000 dollars d'ici 30
ans pour le prix de l'or oui ce qui vous
fait dire ça mais je te nomme conférence
la semaine passée à denver parce que on
voulait c'était le 30e anniversaire de
ses conférences là alors on m'a demandé
de faire une rétrospective de trente ans
que j'ai fait mais dans ma dernière
diapositives
j'ai dit bah écoutez maintenant
j'aimerais voir qu'est ce qui va se
passer dans 30 ans et si vous prenez
simplement la moyenne composée de deux
dernières cinquante ans alors ce qu'on
appelle le quai gare le camp comme
compagne danièle gaudry ces deux pour sa
part année et si vous faites simplement
cette moyenne lorsque vous arrivez au
chiffre de douze mille cinq cents
dollars
maintenant si vous partez en 1989 et
vous prenez les trente dernières années
vous arrivez à 25000 et si vous faites
une moyenne annuelle vous arrivez à 5000
donc là si vous voulez la fourchette et
entre 5 et 25 avec 12500 la moyenne et
ça je pense que c'est absolument si vous
voulez j'ai bien l'impression que les
12500 dans 30 ans à ce report ce poste
le rsa avec la réalité
ça va être la réalité parce que les taux
d'intérêts vendôme et de demeurer bas
parce qu'il y aura plus de leaders
populistes parce qu'il y aura des enjeux
politiques importants parce que
l'économie
rappaz bien si vous voulez parce que les
gouvernements imprime énormément
d'argent
il ya plus de dette que jamais et la
seule façon dont les pays vont être
capables d'effacer ou de d'effacer ou de
rencontrer se déplacer en imprimant de
l'argent et c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça monsieur la sonde
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris ce temps
avec nous bonne chance pour la suite à
la prochaine
c'est moi qui vous remercie infiniment
au revoir au revoir